chaque jour 2500 russe franchissent la
frontière avec l'estonie dans la moitié
des cas grâce à un visa délivré par
tallinn ce ne sera désormais plus le cas
le gouvernement estonien a décidé de
sanctionner la russie en refusant
l'accès aux ressortissants russes
nous ne validerons pas le visa de
manière procédurale il ne sera plus
possible d'entrer en estonie avec ce
visa il de se déplacer en estonie avec
étant donné qu'il n'existe pas beaucoup
de moyens pour entrer depuis la russie
dans l'espace schengen eh bien ces
personnes ne devraient plus pouvoir y
rentrer
des exceptions seront faites pour les
russes installés en estonie ou ceux
devant assister à des funérailles en
dehors de l'estonie d'autres pays de
l'espace schengen frontaliers de la
russie ont aussi annoncé des
restrictions à destination des
ressortissants russes la finlande qui
partagent 1340 kilomètres de frontière
terrestre avec la russie a promis de
réduire de 90% les visas touristiques
aux russes à partir du mois de septembre
la finlande est encore un des rares pays
de l'espace schengen ou l'errance
accélère sans difficulté
l'augmentation du tourisme dans ces
circonstances à poser des questions
d'ordre moral à la population
finlandaise car la finlande accueil en
même temps beaucoup de réfugiés
ukrainien et donc c'est notre manière de
nous positionner face à cette situation
une position qui ne fait pas l'unanimité
au sein de l'union européenne
le chancelier allemand olaf scholz
estime que la fin des visas pourrait
empêcher les dissidents au régime de
vladimir poutine de fuir la russie par
voie terrestre l'espace aérien européen
est déjà fermée à tous les vols en
provenance de russie